hi and welcome to biology professor
today we're going to be talking about
how to use linear regression
to determine an mic
so first of all let's just revisit what
an mic is
it stands for minimum inhibitory
concentration
so m i c the minimum inhibitory
concentration
is the lowest that's why we say minimum
the lowest
concentration of an antimicrobial
compound that will prevent the growth of
a microbe
so whatever is that smallest
concentration
i'll just make one up let's say it's 50
micrograms per milliliter
that prevents 100 of the growth of the
microbe so
may or may not kill the microbe
um but at least does prevent its growth
at that concentration so that's looking
for the lowest concentration that you
can
use to prevent 100 of the growth
now the mic can be determined
by challenging a pure culture of the
microbe
with multiple different concentrations
of a given antimicrobial compound so
let's say that you have
discovered a new pathogen and you want
to know what the mic
of streptomycin is against that pathogen
that would be the lowest concentration
of streptomycin
that would prevent the growth of that
microbe or
you know on the opposite side maybe you
have discovered a new antimicrobial
compound
and you want to know how effective it is
against a known pathogen like
staphylococcus aureus or e coli
and so you want to get pure cultures
of the micro of the microbe or the
bacterium or the fungi or whatever
that you are going to be studying
and challenge it with multiple
concentrations
of the antimicrobial compound that
you're using so
10 micrograms per ml 20 micrograms per
mil 30 micrograms per mil 40 micrograms
per mil so multiple concentrations
and then plotting
the inhibition data using a linear
regression
and we'll talk more about that in a
second first let's talk about what kinds
of data you might be looking at
depending on how you do the challenge
you can have different kinds of data so
for example
you can do a kind of a modified disk
diffusion test
so think like a kirby bower test and
once i modified it's because depending
on the particular
microbe that you're using you might have
to use
different different types of auger
different types of media
you might have to start out with
different amounts of it to make sure you
get a good
thick lawn of growth and so forth but
some kind of disc diffusion test
just as a reminder of what this is this
is where you have a petri dish
and you put a
um enough of the bacterium on there to
result in a lawn
and then you put a disc in the middle
and this disc contains a certain
concentration
that you're testing of antimicrobial uh
of an antonymophobial
compound and then you put it in an
incubator you come back you know 24
hours later
and maybe you have a zone of inhibition
and that means
um you've got basically microbial growth
in a lawn out here and then you have a
zone of inhibition in here
if you want to know more about that you
can check out my video on
the the distribution test but here the
the data that you're getting
is this diameter right here
um the diameter of that zone of
inhibition where the microbial could not
grow so you would have like a zone of
inhibition
measured in you know millimeters you
could also
take these cells and instead of doing a
disc diffusion acid you could put them
in like a 96 well plate
which have these you know 96 little
wells that you put the
bacteria in um and then you put
different concentrations of the
antimicrobial compound in there
and then at the end of a few days you
measure the optical
density
and that is just meaning that you have a
machine that sends some light through
the well and the more bacterial growth
there is the more it will scatter the
light the less light will reach the
detector on the other side
and that's a measure of optical density
that's how you can
see different amounts of bacterial
growth and so of course if there's
no bacterial growth then you've found
the mic
if there's bacterial growth in all of
them then this is where you would use
the linear regression that we'll talk
about next
and another type of data that you can
use is plate counts and so this is where
you maybe have
um a two you know let's say 10 tubes
with this with this microbe in them and
um each of the ten tubes is testing a
different concentration
of the given antimicrobial compound and
then
at the end of let's say 24 hours however
long it takes the bacterium to kind of
grow into get well into that exponential
growth phase
um and then you take maybe a milliliter
from the tubes and do something called a
plate count and that's where you are
putting the the bacteria onto a plate
not with a disc of anti-of antimicrobial
compound but just on a regular plate
and then counting the colony forming
units so counting the colonies to
estimate the number of count
colonies forming units and then um so
these are the three
sort of major different ways that you
could determine
how inhibitory the different
concentrations are
once you've got that data you have to
plot it
to do some kind of linear regression so
here i'm going to just use some made up
example numbers but we've got the
antimicrobial concentration
on the x-axis and your inhibition data
on the y-axis whether that's
cfus or optical densities or what have
you and so
let's say at the you know the lowest
antimicrobial concentration tested we
had
quite a bit of growth still and then
as we test different concentrations and
these are getting
to be larger concentrations each time
maybe we see
something like that and so
what you can do here is you've got your
plotted data
we can see that it's a roughly linear
relationship so we
can have our spreadsheet program whether
you use it using something like excel or
google sheets or another kind of
spreadsheet
or even doing it by hand you can you can
put in a line of best
fit so you do a linear trend line
like that and
wherever that trend line i'm gonna have
to extend my x-axis a little bit
wherever that trend line hits the x-axis
i'm going to put a big circle here
this right here this
x-intercept
is the estimated mic the estimated
minimum inhibitor
concentration and so let's say that you
tested 10 20 30 40 50 60 70 80
micrograms per ml
and maybe that x-intercept is
at 102 micrograms per ml i'm just making
up these numbers right now
then you know that you can go and test
102 micrograms per ml
um also maybe some other numbers on
either side of that you know 101
micrograms per ml 100 micrograms per ml
103 micrograms per ml and so forth
to figure out which concentration
actually
inhibits 100 of the growth of that
microbe and then that would be your mic
now there are some caveats first
the data that i drew up here for us to
work with
was roughly linear you know already but
some relationships are actually going to
be exponential
meaning that you'll see kind of an
exponential curve you might see data
that looks more
like that for example if that's the case
then you can graph the log numbers of
those
to get that linear relationship and then
the intercept would be the logarithm of
the mic and then you can back
calculate the mic from there another
caveat to keep in mind is that some
microbial populations
have mixed susceptibility
and what that means is that you could
have a population of microbes
and you know maybe um 10
of those cells would be outright killed
at the very lowest antimicrobial
concentration
and maybe the reason that you actually
need 102 micrograms per milliliter
is not because that's necessary for all
the cells
but because that's necessary to kill the
last three percent
that are particularly resistant to this
antimicrobial compound
and then the final caveat this is still
and this is an extrapolation right here
and that's still just an estimate
until it's tested
that means you can't just stop with the
intercept the next step
is then to test concentrations
around this and two micrograms per ml so
you test this exactly and then you know
a little bit down from it a little bit
up from it
to really pinpoint the actual
minimum inhibitory concentration so if
you
would like some more information on this
kind of stuff you can check out i
already
mentioned i have a video on the disc
diffusion test you can look more into
that process
if you're interested in how hospitals
look at mics
and analyze how mics are changing in
specific regions you can also see
my video on antibiograms and other than
that thanks for watching biology
professor and i hope to see you next
time